another video we did the recent one on
carl jung and wittgenstein and so on
that one is the highest rated video it
has a high
ratio of likes so not the highest viewed
but highest rated
so let's see if we can break the record
noam chomsky joins us for a second ama
that isn't ask me anything and just like
last time we tried to steer clear from
politics and instead
stay in the philosophical realm the
reasons for this are twofold so number
one you can visit virtually any other
channel with a
video on chomsky recently to get his
views on politics
which they tend to ask the same
questions over and over number two
the reason is that this channel is
dedicated to explicating theories of
everything
which is a physics term but it also has
a philosophical implication of an
all-encompassing world view or at least
one that explains the majority of the
important phenomenon around us it's this
latter definition that i tend to glom
onto more
however unification of quantum physics
with gravity at high energies or
low distances is at least to me required
we touch on several topics such as
kierkegaard roger penrose
cryptocurrencies
the piraha language and even minorly sam
harris even minorly we talk about
psychedelics or at least terence mckenna
if you like content like this then
please consider supporting at
patreon.com
i do plan on having another a third ama
with
chomsky sometime before the end of this
year i cannot guarantee that
however each dollar helps not only with
finances
but with encouragement and reassurance
that
this is something that is worth
supporting
thank you so much i appreciate your
viewership i hope that you enjoy it
those ear pieces really work
yeah they work great my experiment with
them seems some
not hearing very well on the internet
oh yeah i can tell because sometimes
when i ask questions i see you lean
forward
because i imagine you're trying to
listen intently
pick up the yeah they just relay it
straight to your ear
directly many of these questions are
from your fans
some are also from professors i'll start
with the professors first
okay ian mcgillicrist
he is the writer of master and its
emissary
he says can you ask chomsky what he
would say to someone who thought
language was not
in itself required for thought or
communication
but instead arose to make manipulation
more effective manipulation of the world
or of people or of objects and so on
well the question is questions like that
always
bring to my mind some comments which
i may have mentioned in our earlier
discussions
one by alan turing
another by ludwig wittgenstein
at about the same time in fact at a time
when
turing and wittenstein were in
communication
uh turing's comment is in his
famous paper which initiated the field
of
artificial intelligence is paper 1950
paper
on can machines on machine
thinking can machines think and
touring points out correctly
that the question can machines think
is too meaningless to deserve discussion
the reason it doesn't develop it is
clear
because we simply have no independent
concept
of thought uh we have a when he was
asked what thought is he said
some kind of buzzing in the head we
don't know what it is
uh i think we can do better than that
and in fact
comment expands on this
probably independently uh he says
he his typical aphoristic style you have
to
interpret what it means it says
people think maybe dolls and spirits
what that means is the way we use the
word
think we apply it to people and what
people are doing
the word has like all words has open
what's called open texture it's not
precisely defined it has a
number of possible interpretations at
the fringe
and we extend it to things that we
think of as being rather like people
okay so he says dolls and spirits but
maybe your pet dog you know whatever
but the point is there's really no
answer to these questions
we have a by now we have a
pretty clear reasonably well worked out
conception of what linguistic
expressed thought is doesn't have to be
articulated most of it's internal but
it's linguistically
formulated so we have some understanding
of what linguistically formulated
thought is
but we have no concept beyond that
so the question that's asked is just in
an area where
you can say whatever you like because we
have no answers
like i happen to have a couple of dogs
lying under the desk right now as far as
i'm aware they have about
10 ideas in their mind i don't want to
say them although
immediately react but uh
maybe there's more maybe there isn't you
know
i'm surprised you even used the term
d-o-g
you actually said the word because
before well if you were scared too
unknown so they don't race right for the
door as soon as i see it
great now some of these questions i
don't have the username
i'll try my best to say the person's
full name or username when i can
but this one just says what do you see
as your life's mission
yes your life's mission
my life's mission i'm
not i'm not that exalted uh they have
their
tasks that i'd like to perform uh
immediate ones longer term ones
questions i'd like to
help find answers to the human problems
i'd like to help to solve
uh that's uh family
happy family i care for uh
those are enough for life's mission
professor stuart hameroff asks what do
you think of hammeroff's idea
about x-bar structure in microtubules
x-bar structure in language yes
well there was a there was a time when
the
move to x-bar structure was a positive
move
uh back in the 1960s
came to be recogni at the time the
say mid-60s the mechanisms for
language description were basically
structural rules and transformational
rules
there were inadequacies in both systems
price structure rules had very severe
inadequacies
one of them is they're too rich
so there's nothing in the theory of
phrase structure
which says you can't have a rule
noun phrase arrow preposition
uh adjective phrase possible rule
but of course language doesn't have such
rules
and if a theory permits
impossible rules that's a
refutation of the theory also there were
hidden assumptions sneaked in
illegitimately into phrase structure
so for example when you have the symbol
vp
the hidden assumption is it's based on v
but that's an illegitimate assumption
uh the rule vp arrow v
np standard rule saying a verb can take
an object
that's no different from x arrow y z
then the rest is illegitimate
assumptions
so x bar theory was
created as a way to eliminate the
illegitimate assumptions
and have a narrower system closer to
what the actual language with the nature
of language is
and it it did overcome those
two difficulties that i mentioned it
ruled out those illegitimate rules
it had its own problems which weren't
discovered until
quite a few years later they should have
been recognized at once
x-bar theory forces everything
into the um into
what's called an endocentric mode
meaning that each phrase has to be a
projection
of a particular lexical head
so a verb phrase is a prediction of the
noun phrases a projection of n
but there are plenty of constructions in
language
which just don't have that property in
fact one of them is a simple subject
predicate construction
that's why if you look back at the early
rules the first one is
s arrow npvp
the traditional subject predicate
relation
but that's not an endocentric
construction
and there are others in fact every case
of displacement moving one phrase to
some different place
yields a non-endocentric construction
now the way this was handled was just by
forcing these
into some endocentric frame by
arbitrary stipulations but that's no
good
theory you know theory should have
arbitrary stipulations
so x-bar theory was flawed as well
and later developments have enabled us
to
overcome these flaws and develop
what's called the merch-based system
which
associated with labeling conventions
which
overcome fundamental flaws of x-bar
theory
so i think it was a stage that was
important
we then move on to a better stage
i expect we'll move on to better ones as
we proceed
science doesn't come to an end
have you happened to read roger
penrose's emperor's new mind
and if so what do you think about it
roger penrose's paper run
he had a book called emperor's new mind
oh
well he's a brilliant scientist
is exciting and interesting to read his
work
a lot of it i i'm not competent to have
a judgment about
some of it in areas i know something
about is
suggestive but not really
confirmed or clear enough to proceed
with
but it's very much worth reading
professor vino voloneck of concordia
university asks
the derivational theory of complexity
was created and rejected when cognitive
neuroscience
was at a relatively early underdeveloped
stage
since generative grammars are realist
theories
that are supposed to characterize the
actual functioning of the brain
do you think that the derivational
theory of complexity
was discarded prematurely and that
recent advancements in neuroscience
and brain imaging have the potential to
vindicate it
well the derivational theory of
complexity was an interesting idea
proposed by george miller
friend and colleague or
fine outstanding psychologist back
probably late 50s early 60s so the idea
was that
you could measure the complexity of
processing of an expression by looking
at the number of operations that
entered into generating it
they had some initial successes with
experiments
then they started not working
there was also another problem it was
based on
conceptions of language that were
fairly prevalent at the time but these
keep changing
as we learn more as in the example we
just discussed
about x-bar theory and that means that
the ranking of expressions in terms of
derivational complexity
changes as the theories change well for
an experimentalist that's
a problem means you have to redo the
experiments every time some new idea
shows up
these problems lead to pretty much
abandonment of the idea
maybe with more refined theories it
might be possible
to reconstitute it the more general
question that's
raised by the questioner is the relation
between
the theories postulated within the study
of
generative grammar and the actual
neural realization of them there there's
a big gap
but there's the same gap for everything
else
the brain sciences are not
at a state where you can
relate any moderately complex trait to
what's going on in the brain
you can do it very loosely you know i
can say this area of the brain is
firing when you're doing so and so
but what's going on in that area of the
brain we know
very little about here's where penrose
has actually
had some ideas about quantum theoretic
approaches to the internal
structure of neurons which has a rich
internal
structure possibly a basis for
a great deal of computation but not very
much is understood about that
if that's correct the whole structure
of much of the
brain side of the neuroscience is
on the wrong track when it's looking at
neural nets and there's
other reasons to think that so basically
we don't really know where to look
now randy galissell has done very
important work on this
is i think very convincing work showing
that
neural nets just do not have the
possible possibility of
developing the core element
in any computational system
just doesn't have that capacity so
using the model of which he sometimes
does of the
drunk looking under the lamppost for his
watch
which he lost somewhere else but when
asked why are you looking here
he says that's because that's where the
light is but
the light is where you have neural nets
but it's probably not where things are
happening
so this is not a criticism of the brain
sciences it's very hard
in particular if you take a look at say
the study of language
the study of the neural basis of
language
is extraordinarily hard because you
cannot do
experiments you can imagine all kinds of
experiments
invasive experiments that would give
rich information about the nature of
language and its use but you can't do
the experiments
for ethical reasons we just don't allow
invasive experiments with humans like
say raising a
child under controlled conditions or
sticking electrodes into the brain or
something like that
now we do allow it rightly or wrongly
at least we used to may not anymore with
other animals
okay so in fact we've learned a great
deal about
the neuroscience of human vision
by invasive experiments with uh
cats let's say for example the famous
hubil weasel nobel prize winning
experiments which
gave a tremendous amount of information
about
peripheral processing of visual stimuli
and cats since humans have about the
same visual system as cats
it's apparently true of humans too so we
know
a lot about that but in the case of
language
there's no other organism there's no
there are no analogous systems in other
organisms
it's essentially unique so even if we
allowed
invasive experimentation say with
chimpanzees or
crows or whatever other birds show
high level of animals show high levels
of
some kind of intellectual activity it's
no use
because they don't have these systems
so the in multiple ways study of the
neural basis for language extremely
difficult
there are results but they're limited
there's another problem all of the
studies that are carried out
are studies of the use of language
but there's a fundamental distinction
which actually goes back to aristotle
between possession of knowledge and use
of knowledge
those are two distinct things modern
terms it's called
competence and performance now what we
observe
is the use of knowledge but there's
something else
the storage of knowledge what's the
nature of the system that's stored that
you access
and using it and we don't know how to
experiment with that
you just don't know where to look uh
actions at least you know where to look
person is saying something you can see
what area of the brain
fires up you know but or if there's
a language disorder you can see if the
the actions of using the language are
related to some area of the brain that
might be affected
there's a lot of work on that but it's
all
study of production or sometimes
perception of language
that's use of the system not the nature
of the system which remains fixed no
matter how you use it
we have the same store of knowledge
whether we're using it or not
john clever asks what's chomsky's
thoughts on kierkegaard
and the existentialists in general
i find it interesting
and provocative to read but it
i don't get i can't draw conclusions
from it with regard to my own
either thinking about intellectual
problems or or the way
i live or think about life doesn't
doesn't resonate with me
so it's interesting literature but like
a lot of literature it's hard to say
what the impact is
what does chomp oh this comes from naman
or naman
what does chomsky think of sam harris's
views on
islam that is that islam's
is yeah islam's ideologies are
incompatible with human rights
so what does chomsky think about this
it's both ignorant and racist
not worth discussing in my opinion
based on the chat during the live stream
and even afterward
someone told me to bring up ayan hersey
ali to demonstrate that it's not
racism per se but i didn't see these
messages until later so i emailed
chomsky and got this as a response
i'd have to look at it but there would
be no contradiction in jews making
anti-semitic comments
former muslims making racist comments
about muslims etc
okay this person their name is cross
your genitals
terence mckenna posited that
psychedelics
were the evolutionary catalyst that
propelled mankind
into projective imagination and language
as a linguist
do you consider psychedelics as
important to the evolution of language
there's a lot of speculation about that
but
i don't know of anything substantive
furthermore i don't see how it could
possibly work
i don't see any imaginable connection
between whatever effect psychedelic
states
have on people and the
either the combinatorial
properties that yield the basic form of
language
or the concepts that we use
when we're constructing thought in
language
there's just no connection that anyone
can
point to
slavin iv asks what does he think of
multi-level selection and or group
selection group selection
i think i don't want to claim to have a
sophisticated answer to this question i
don't
i think there are arguments in favor of
group selection which can't be ignored
uh whether they're definitive
i'm not in a position to say
throwing snow asks i'd love to know if
chomsky believes that cryptocurrencies
can really decentralize the financial
world
and if that's even beneficial to society
at large
decentralization of financial
institutions
via cryptocurrencies or the
popularization of them well that's
i mean this is a question that arises at
many different levels but one of them
has to do with central banks
the other has to do with investment
banks
banks all together you know so on
finance private financial institutions
central bank is essentially a government
institution though it's supposed to
function independently of the government
and these are different questions i mean
modern state capitalist societies
i don't think could function without
some kind of central bank
on the other hand the individual banks
have way too much power they're
probably harmful to the economy they've
grown
enormously in the past 40 years if you
go back to
1950 and 1960
first of all banks were tightly
regulated
and they were basically uh
closely connected to the real economy
a bank was a place where you could put
extra money if you
didn't want to use it right now you
could go to the bank for a loan to buy a
car
you know things like that that's what a
bank was
not now after 40 years of neoliberalism
banks just have an overwhelming role in
the economy
there's a huge amount of trading that
goes on
which has nothing to do with the real
economy
in fact it's often and of course they're
subject continued
crises and collapses in fact they
probably even couldn't survive without a
major public subsidy
the international monetary fund did a
study a few years ago of the top
the major us banks i think the top six
or so banks
and asking simply where does their
profit come from
it turns out their profit comes
overwhelmingly
from a government insurance policy
a policy that in
its public version is too big to fail
what it means is an implicit guarantee
by the government
that we're not going to let you collapse
because you're too big
that leads of course to regular
huge bailouts after a crisis
but much more than that it means the
banks
have access to cheap credit
they get inflated credit ratings
they can borrow on cheap terms they can
engage the investment banks can engage
in
risky activity which is quite profitable
in the short term and if it crashes
the friendly tax carrier will come in
and
bail them out so they have the numerous
advantages
that joins hard to put a number on them
bloomberg businessweek did an analysis
and estimated on the basis of the imf
figures that would might amount to maybe
80 billion dollars a year of subsidy
that's a fair amount of money it's not
clear that
and more recent studies indicate that
financial institutions contribute to the
economy up to a certain level
beyond that they probably harm it in
many ways
it's pretty interesting that economists
have
not done very much study of this back
after the
crash of 2008 2009
crash was caused by predatory
lending
methods of big investment firms and
banks
which were permitted by the deregulation
the massive deregulation of the
clinton administration robert rubin
lord summers others said you know
deregulate everything
which led to real criminal behavior on
the part of the banks
when it all crashed the government has
to step in and
yell them out it was the worst of
periodic crashes since reagan
there weren't many before because things
were controlled
uh there were some
reflections on this by leading
economists i remember
an article by robert solo nobel laureate
economist very
smart guy in uh daedalus the journal of
the american
academy of arts and sciences in which he
raised the question whether the fanatic
huge financial institutions are a
benefit or a drain on the economy
and he pointed out that economists had
given very little study to this
which is kind of striking because
especially over the
40-year liberal years they just become
an overwhelming part of the economy
but they didn't fit into the models that
economists were looking at
and he tried to give a
back of the envelope calculation and
concluded they're
probably harmful there's much more study
now which i think
gives greater weight to that conclusion
and there are many ways of cutting back
their
way massive oversized role
one very straightforward way is just the
financial transaction tax
small tax on every
uh financial interaction
doesn't for the sum of money that would
be collected as
huge be a huge benefit to the
it goes right to the government which
could be used for productive purposes
for the bank and what it would do is
sharply cut back
uh trading that is irrelevant to the
economy
an awful lot of the trading that goes on
much of it automated by now
is just i can make a little bit of money
by moving something from here to here so
let's do it
there's nothing to do with the economy
enriches
various extraordinarily rich segments of
the economy
and all of that could be cut out just by
simple transaction tax financial
transaction tax
would move the financial institutions
closer to having something to do with
the real economy
but even beyond that it's a question
whether they shouldn't be broken up
why should they be bailed out every time
they crash why not break them up
if i want to put them under popular
control why not have public banks
and why not have the post office be used
as a
simple bank which people could use
because it's right there and you put
money in it take money out
there are lots of ways of cutting back
on the
extraordinary power and basically
harmful role of these huge institutions
i think those are steps that can easily
be taken
and should be nothing longer
you can ask what are these institutions
about all together but that
has to do with the nature of state
capitalist society
tarek from youtube right now live wants
to know what does
chomsky think of elon musk's neura link
so far it's high in the sky
a lot of money is going into it
nobody has the slightest idea whether
there's any scientific basis to it or
everybody could possibly learn anything
from it
so it's uh you know maybe something will
come out of it
maybe not but it's pretty much a shot in
the dark
i don't see any scientific basis for it
can't show that nothing will happen
maybe it will
but to me it looks like a publicity
stunt frame
okay ryan in portland oregon asks
thank you so much for providing this
opportunity i never post online but i
can't help myself
does chomsky think that douglas
hofstetter's theory of mind
that is that the mind is a recursive
loop or a strange
loop is in line with generative grammar
so that is is douglas hofstetter's
theory of mind
in line with generative grammar
particularly
the idea that sensory data leads to
symbols in the brain
i mean something is going on in the
brain when you
he's a very smart guy and very
interesting to read so i think
you can always get a lot out of reading
him but
what does it mean for sensory day to
have a symbol in the brain
something's going on in the brain when i
see a
red light and stop when i'm driving
is there a symbol in the brain that says
red
we don't have any theory of
how the brain works that in which such a
notion
fits in a fashion that yields
explanations of anything
i mean there are
there are something
the nature of what is happening in the
brain
is very obscure we can
say at an app in a very abstract way
very abstra abstracting from what may be
going on in the brain
we can maybe develop some account in
which
red red sensory
sensation written qualia
maps to it a symbol that enters into
some
computational procedure but
that's extremely remote from what may
actually be happening in the brain
and the theories that do it are very
weak they use it don't really tell you
very much
they just pretty much translate ordinary
experience into
a technical terminology
the platypus king asks i was wondering
if professor
chomsky has ever addressed peter
singer's
drowning child thought experiment
and what he makes of it this is his
theory of whether
defective children should be allowed to
develop and grow
no that let's say you see a child
drowning
20 meters a child drowning in a pond
close to you you can save the child
and all it would cost you would be your
clothes okay
most people would do that but then
imagine
sorry right to say
to save the child but then what about a
child that is
far away in africa costs the same
something like kin selection uh
should we in fact obey the principle
which underlies kin selection
of being more concerned about
the ch our own child than the child
across the street
that's a little bit like asking should
we be human beings
or not human beings it's instinctive
in human beings to be more concerned
about
what's close to you there are theories
like
hamilton's selection theory that try to
go back to the evolutionary origins of
it
and i don't think
anything is going to modify that
you can ask whether if we were some
other organism
in some different universe could we
behave
differently but i don't think there's
any
general principles that bear on this our
ethical systems relate and will never
escape the nature of our human
our human our actual human nature and
capacities
maybe some of them by some other
standards should be changed but we don't
know what those are the standards are
now this seems to me no it's okay in a
philosophy seminar but it has nothing to
do with
the ethical problems that humans face
sure we should be
concerned about a child starving in
bangladesh
but instead of discussing this in a
philosophy seminar
what we should be doing is doing
something about it
okay we should be acting to overcome
those problems where we can we can't do
it everywhere
we can do it in a lot of places and
these are very con
what interests me about these questions
are not
what you can talk about in a philosophy
seminar but very
concrete real examples
so let's take uh unrwa
the united nations relief reconstruction
agency
a lot of children in the world depend on
it for survival
we react to that by cutting off the
funds to it
okay so in uh say in gaza
one of the most miserable dangerous
place horrible places in the world
unrwa was a lifeline for survival
for hundreds of thousands of children
plenty of others that's a real question
what do we do about it we cut off the
lifeline
because president trump said
palestinians
aren't nice enough to me so i'm gonna
cut off their lifeline
that's the kind of thing we should be
talking about
it's not of much interest in my view to
have a
philosophical discussion about whether
in principle we ought to be
concerned about a child somewhere else
as much as their own
we're not going to find that answer to
that but we can find an
answer to this and it's very real and
immediate
and there are many such cases all over
the world
all the time like just recent history
of the current history right now there's
a massive
problem providing
vaccines to people who need them
okay just a couple of days ago
president biden took
vaccines from a store
that's stored in the united states the
astrazeneca
vaccines which can't be used in the
united states because they've not yet
been approved by the
federal drug agency so they just stored
and he decided the united states they
decided to give them the countries
to other countries which countries
canada which is the world champion
for storing vaccines they can't use
more than any other country it's stored
excess vaccines
instead of giving so we'll hand them to
canada to mexico
why to mexico because it's part of a
bargain
to try to induce mexicans to break
international law
by keeping people fleeing
from misery in central america from
reaching our borders
but why not give the vaccines to africa
for example
where they need them okay well
that's a real problem these are the
problems on the front pages
every day so let's worry about those
time and energy are finite
we have to distribute our energy and
efforts
i think there are much higher priorities
than an abstract discussion
about whether by some ethical system we
don't have
we should be just as concerned for the
child across the street as for our own
it's a something to think about
in your spare time but meanwhile we have
overriding practical questions
of life and death now this vaccine
problem is a very striking one all
of the wealthy countries are trying to
monopolize vaccines
some are storing them way beyond what
they need
like canada for example others are
taking them for themselves not giving
them to the people who need them
that's not only deeply unethical
by any ethical standards but it also is
well known that it's suicidal
it's a few don't allow
people in africa and asia to be
vaccinated
the virus is going to mutate that will
mutate the forms which will be lethal
for us
so here we have a situation where the
rich
powerful and educated are carrying out
actions
which are in the first place deeply
immoral
and in the second place suicidal
and they're doing it on the basis of
this
principle we have to take care of
ourselves first
now that's a real question let's think
about that one
what do you disagree about most with
stephen pinker
and why do you think he believes
whatever it is that disagreement is
given that he's not evil or stupid why
is he so mistaken in your opinion
well i don't like to answer talk about
things at that level of generality
he's a personal friend we agree on some
things disagree on others
if you can mention the things we
disagree on
be glad to talk about them but i don't
feel i can make general sure the person
wants to know what you disagree
with him most on well we have
very different pictures of conceptions
of
all kinds of things ranging from
evolution of
language to the nature of society
many great differences i think but
could talk about individual things but
yuval harari in his book sapiens
theorizes that language evolved in
humans
as a consequence of thought and
imagination
not principally as a form of
communication
your own work in independent theory
suggests a clear link between cognition
and language any thoughts on the notion
that language evolved
as an introspective tool first
well this this is not a question of
speculation
but of scientific research
so how do you proceed to answer the
question
well do you want to know how some system
evolved
the first thing you have to ask is what
is the nature of the system
it's pointless to ask how
say complex cells
evolve without knowing the nature of a
complex cell
that's truism study of evolution begins
with
understanding the phenotype so what's
the nature of language we have to begin
with that speculation about how it
evolved is completely idle
unless it's based on an understanding of
the system that evolved
so we take a look at the system that
evolved and i think we find
pretty convincing if not overwhelming
evidence
that its nature its design if you like
to call it that without
any implications about designers just
the technical notion of design
its structure nature is
as fundamentally a system of thought
it turns out that there are for example
conflict in the nature of language
between computational efficiency
being a computationally perfect
instrument object and communicative
efficiency
use for utility for thought every case
that we know of
communicate efficiency is sacrificed
it's just
not an issue so it seems that
language is based on
concepts of computational efficiency
what mother nature would do if she was
trying to find the simplest
computational process which would yield
the basic structure of language
what we find is case after case
it picks nature picks the solution which
yields
thought doesn't care about whether it
harms communication or not
we also find that the part that
language basic language is essentially
bifurcated there's an internal
system which effectively
generates thoughts and there's a mode of
externalizing it taking what's internal
and turning it into some sensory motor
output
typically sound the could be sign could
even be touch
can't be smelled because we don't have
refined enough
sense of smell but the externalization
is just to
some sensory motor system well there's
by now
quite extensive evidence that the
externalization system
does not enter into the functioning of
the internal system
you can run through some of the evidence
but i think it's
quite convincing so and furthermore the
externalization system seems to be
ancillary to language in other respects
not only does it not enter into the
functioning of the
mode of construction of expressions
which are expressions of thought
but it also has huge numbers of
it also seems to be the locus of
the apparent diversity and complexity
and mutability of language
and in fact if you think about it the
externalization system
is not strictly speaking part of
language
the externalization system is
by its nature an amalgam of
whatever the internal system is and the
nature of the sensory motor system
in which it's being expressed
and the sensory motor systems are
totally independent of language
they existed long before a language
emerged
they haven't been affected by the
appearance of language and other
organisms
like say apes and pretty much
share the sensory motor system but
i'm not uh even the basic rudiments of
language
so it seems to be systems that are kind
of peripheral to
an external to language and those are of
course the systems used for
communication
so when we put all this together
it turns out that very strong reason to
believe
that language evolved as a
a system of computation which
generates thoughts and then tacked onto
it
are modes of uh spread
or externalize it in some sensory mode
or medium
if that's the case then language did not
evolve as an instrument of communication
but that's the kind of thinking that has
to go on
maybe you can question the steps but
it's
clear that the study to begin with
we're not going to learn about the
evolution of any system
except to the extent that we understand
the nature of that system that's general
for language or anything else
mahendra varma asks daniel
everett and others claim that the piraha
language deviates from universal grammar
but the papers and book they produced
are unconvincing
and don't tell much or present much data
can you professor chomsky argue on
behalf of them such as
professor daniel everett and so on and
explain their case
and then rebut it well the
piranha story began as an error
that has by now turned into a fraud
uh there is nothing to it
daniel everett misread the
papers that he was referring to all of
them
he assumed that they were saying that
all languages must use unbounded
recursion
no paper ever said that nothing
what was said is that the capacity for
unbounded recursion is part of the
general faculty of language that's a
crucial difference
there's plenty of things in the faculty
of language
that individual languages don't use so
for example
english doesn't use the emphatic
consonants of arabic
okay english doesn't use the
inflectional system of czech you know
okay
plenty of things that are not used in
individual languages
but they're part of the faculty of
language they're available
to the language learner immediately
all available and acquisition of
language is a matter of picking out
among them
so in the first place the purana example
has
zero nothing to do with universal
grammar
that was just an error of reading
misreading the papers that was pointed
out very quickly
it's in the it's in the technical
professional literature right away
well okay people make mistakes uh
the right way to respond when a mistake
is
exposed is to withdraw the claim
well that hasn't happened in fact it's
become a huge
publicity thing in the newspapers and so
on where people have no idea what the
issue is
at that point it begins to verge on
fraud i'm sorry to say
uh but the fact of the matter is it's
it has about as much to do with language
as if uh
suppose we found a tribe somewhere where
people
ever from infancy children are
given a black patch to put over one eye
well they would not have binocular
vision
in fact you know from experiments with
their animals that the
visual system would deteriorate and
accommodate in fact
this is known for children in fact when
you
have a child i in fact had a child who
we discovered when she was an infant
that she wasn't using one eye
she was just looking at things with her
other eye which is not unusual
so the way they handled it is by putting
a patch over the eye that she uses
to force use of the other eye then
gradually the brain accommodates and use
both
but suppose you had a tribe where people
put
a patch on one eye then the
children who grew up would be
essentially blind in one eye
would that tell you anything about
binocular vision
of course not binocular vision is a prop
is a an element of the
nature of the visual system if some
particular group doesn't use it
tells you nothing about the visual
system similarly
if piranha didn't use unbounded
recursion will tell you nothing about
the
universal grammar nothing whatsoever in
fact it's probably
not true about the language but that's a
side issue
in any event the whole thing is a
compass and a teapot there's actually
nothing there
the only question that arises is whether
in fact this
language has the properties that ever
claimed many
linguists say it doesn't but okay it's a
question
technical question about one particular
language
with no implications at all
for universal grammar or for anything
more general
mediocre bat wants to know i'd like to
know if chomsky has any thoughts on carl
fristen's
free energy principle i've heard of it
but
the little i've seen about it didn't
encourage me to look any further frankly
i don't know of any such principle that
has any consequences or implications
my april wants to know the mysteries
chomsky pursues
and feels awestruck by well
i'm all struck by for example the same
things that
galileo was awestruck by
galileo and his contemporaries were
carrying out in the 17th century a
major revision of the whole
picture of science that's the birth of
modern science
questioning everything reconstructing it
and so on
and one of the topics that they were
interested in was
that struck there that captured their
attention was language
and they expressed galileo and others
expressed their
or awe and
amazement at um
an astonishing property of ordinary
language
somehow with a handful of
symbols a couple of dozen symbols we can
construct in our minds infinitely many
thoughts which is already
kind of miraculous how can this happen
and in addition
we can find a way to
convey these thoughts to the minds of
others
who have no access to our minds
now galileo regarded the alphabet as the
most stupendous of human inventions
uh the level of uh michelangelo or
repetition
his contemporaries had the same view
i think they were right it's what i've
sometimes called the
galilean challenge how can this
miracle be achieved for descartes
this was essentially one of the basic
reasons why
he established mind as a
entity distinct from body because of the
way in which
language is used creatively to express
an infinity of thoughts which have never
been heard before and
can somehow enable others who have no
access to our minds
enable them to nevertheless understand
let's see
grasp the workings of our minds that he
thought required
something outside the mechanical
universe
so that oh and amazement i think remains
we understand some parts of it not
others
seif b asks does a society's
ability to engage and question
answering sorry question asking slash
answering dictate the moral fabric they
operate under
moral problem but we should certainly
ask
the one of the
let's go back to the scientific
revolution
the great achievement of the scientific
revolution
was to be puzzled about what seems
obvious
that's a hard step to take we live in a
world where we just take things for
granted
so for example we take for granted
that the best thing in life the highest
goal
is to get a job uh if you
talk to a young person they want advice
uh you tell them uh
make sure when you're at school you get
the
capacity to get a job when you graduate
well galileo was questioning whether we
should believe
the ideas about the world which say that
objects fall because the ground is their
natural place
should we accept that or should we
reject it and
subject to an analysis we could ask the
same question about getting a job
and we're not asking a new question for
two millennia not a short time
right through the 19th century the idea
of getting a job
was regarded as a fundamental
attack against basic human rights
and human dignity why because getting a
job
means accepting servitude to a master
it means saying okay i'll rent myself to
you
for my entire waking life almost
most of my waking life and i will follow
your orders
during this period that was considered
an
utter abomination by now it's
sort of taken for granted but should we
take it for granted
or should we go back to the ideals of
[Music]
working people classical liberals
cicero all the way back abraham lincoln
saying that this is not a decent way for
human beings to live
people should be in control of their own
work and their own destiny
one of the founders of
classical liberalism wilhelm von
humboldt
captured the point very lucidly he said
suppose an artisan creates a beautiful
object
on command and a job
we may admire what he did
but we despise what he is
a tool in the hands of others
that was common belief right through the
19th century
so common in fact that it was a slogan
of
abraham lincoln's republican party
that what they call what was called wage
slavery in those days
is the same as slavery except the
contemporary
till you gain your freedom well we've
lost that
we now accept that putting yourself
renting yourself into servitude is one
of the highest goals in life
an idea that would have been an
abomination for 2000 years
okay it's the kind of thing we should
question
uh we should question lots of things
that are
simply taken for granted and the ability
to question to be puzzled to open your
mind
that's not only the basis for scientific
advancement but also for advancement in
our lives
towards a world of greater freedom and
justice
kinds of questions that always should be
raised
and we find if we raise them horizons
open
that you hadn't thought of before so
this ability to question and be puzzled
is one
we don't have to cultivate it with young
children
because they have it automatically
everyone who's spent any time with young
children
knows they're constantly asking why in
fact it gets irritating at some point
but they're right they want to know why
not just take it for granted
we should not drive that capacity
out of people's minds a lot of education
stifles that instinct
drives children to and students to
obey the most extreme version of this is
the prevalent ideas of teaching to test
you don't teach so the student will
learn
but you teach so that it'll pass a test
okay every one of us has been through
that
we know that if we take a course that
we're
not interested in but we want to get
into college so
you study hard for the exam
you pass it two weeks later you forgot
what the course was about
okay that's the worst possible form of
education
it's driving out of students minds
just which should be cultivated and
encouraged
namely the capacity to question
to be puzzled to ask why
not be satisfied because when you say oh
it's obvious
that's just the kind of thing that
should be questioned so yes there's a
lot at stake in this
zo what says you have criticized
obscurantist philosophers like
slavoy zizek derida and foucault
in the past what about hegel and
heidegger
well it's very hard to comment on
somebody
quite generally i haven't read very much
hagel i don't
get much out of it but i have read some
things like his
lectures on the philosophy of history
i've even written some about it
which i thought was astonishing
in some of its extraordinary
racism and incomprehension
that's what struck me about it i didn't
find
much in the way of stimulation of ideas
might be my fault
maybe i'm missing things you know
don't claim to understand everything by
any means
but anyway what i've read of hagel never
tempted me to go much further rightly or
wrongly
what about heidegger heidegger
most of the time i have no idea what
he's talking about
i i started reading introduction to
metaphysics
when i was a college student
but a little way in i was
so appalled by the apologetics for
nazism
that i just couldn't bring myself to go
on
maybe i missed something maybe not a lot
of it struck me as
empty verbiage didn't see anything there
again maybe i'm missing something
this was back in the early 50s
incidentally
i was kind of shocked later to discover
that many years later
the intellectual world discovered that
to its amazement that
heidegger had been a nazi sympathizer it
springs out of his work
instantly as soon as you look at it now
that's not a reason to reject somebody's
thought
but for me it was a personal reason not
to go on
i can tolerate a lot of things but
there are choices
wants to know if you could answer or
acquire the answer to any one
mystery what mystery would it be
there are many mysteries i'd like to
solve some
on an intellectual level some
on a human level so let me just mention
two i'm sure i could think of many more
on an intellectual level
i would very much like to solve the
problem that i called galileo's
challenge
how and descartes challenged how
are these miracles possible
we haven't the slightest idea
we can understand the mechanisms
that enter into these
actions free creative use of language
haven't the slightest idea how it's
exercised i think that's true of
voluntary motion generally the
leading scientists who study the
neuroscience of voluntary motion
i don't mean complicated things like
speaking but
simple things like say raising your
finger
trying to decide what goes on when you
decide to raise your fingers
you have no idea what they say
the two leading scientists actually
former colleagues of mine at mit when i
was at mit
emilio beatsie uh
robert of jamie and they wrote a
state of the art paper not long ago in
which
they put it as they say rather
fancifully
that we can understand we're coming to
understand
the puppet and the strings but we have
nothing to say about the puppeteer
and it's a very mysterious fact because
even for the most simple actions like
this
why not there's experimental evidence
showing
that the decision to raise
your finger is made about
a half a second before you become
conscious of deciding it
so the decision is made preconsciously
in ways which you have no understanding
of it at a
much richer level it becomes the
question of how
you and i are doing what we're doing
right now
how can we constantly be engaging in
this process of
creating new structures new thoughts
maybe new in the history of the language
others understand them instantly
and can somehow penetrate
to our minds even though they have no
access to our minds
just through the use of a few symbols
all of that is
highly mysterious i know i'm never going
to solve it
in fact humans may never solve it maybe
beyond human capacity
but it would be an amazing discovery
now turning to the human level there is
an astonishing problem that we're facing
right now an overwhelming problem
for the first time in the history
of the human species we have to decide
quickly whether the human experiment
will
continue or whether it's soon
going to end in an inglorious
catastrophe
now there are two major problems issues
one of them is heating the planet
if it goes on on the present course
we will soon be at a level where
human survival is impossible that's
not seriously in doubt we know
how to and the same is true of nuclear
weapons
the threat of the use of nuclear weapons
is sharply increasing
of chances of surviving that are very
slight
in both cases and in fact in every other
case of a major problem
we have answers there are
feasible solutions they're right on the
table
and spill them out perfectly feasible
solutions
we have a brief period in which we can
grasp the opportunity and solve the
problems now here comes the question
humans are not doing it they are
racing to disaster it's kind of like
what i said about the vaccines
by monopolizing the vaccines
not only is criminal ethically but it's
suicidal
these are things that we all we know we
know
we're engaged in suicidal activity we
know that there are answers
here they are but we can't act on the
answers
now the question is can humans
develop the will and the
moral and intellectual capacities which
will
enable them to save the species
from essential destruction in the not
distant future if that question isn't
answered
nothing else matters there were two
great questions left toward the end that
i didn't get a chance to get to
so i emailed chomsky and he promptly
responded
what do you think of language models
like gbt3 from open ai
provided that you've heard of it chomsky
said it's not a language model
it works just as well for impossible
languages as for actual languages
it is therefore refuted if intended as a
language model by normal scientific
criteria
independently of the refutation the way
it works has no relation to language or
cognition generally
perhaps it's useful for some purpose but
it seems to tell us nothing about
language or cognition generally the last
question was
do you fear death what are your brief
thoughts on it
when i was a young teenager chomsky says
i was concerned that when my
consciousness disappeared the whole
world would disappear with it
it soon passed death is a stage of life
i know of nothing more to say about it
well i'm afraid i'll have to take off to
go
okay the last question if you don't mind
someone wants to know what advice you
have for a young person
what advice do you have for a a person
growing up who wants to be somewhat like
you
i wouldn't advise anyone to be someone
like me they should be who they are
the advice is find out who you are go
back to the
one of the earliest questions asked in
intellectual history by the
priestess of the delphic oracle
in ancient greece her she had very
simple advice
her advice was know thyself
uh that's the beginning find out who you
are what kind of person you are
what matters to you what's significant
to you
what engages your imagination what
grasps your hopes and concerns and
pursue it it's the only advice i know
the advice of the priestess it's a good
start
thank you thank you so much i appreciate
you being extremely generous with your
time
i'll email you and let you know how this
video performs compared to the others
but either way thank you so much there's
300 people watching and i didn't i got
to
less than one percent of the questions
thank you for watching thank you for the
questions
and the opportunity to discuss it with
you very much enjoyed it
thank you professor bye-bye
okay well thank you everyone
if you see me looking off to the side
it's because i'm trying to read
some of your questions
you